foreign
in Gainesville Florida what's up Ryan
Dr deloney thank you for having me of
course man thank you for calling in what
up
um I'm having some guilt um I don't know
if I'm doing the right thing as far as
my situation goes okay hold on before
you tell me
I'm only
I tend to believe that guilt well no
okay I'm gonna interrupt you go ahead I
was gonna I was gonna
I've just been wrestling with something
just philosophical but this isn't the
time or place for my stuff so go ahead
you go with you go ahead Ryan
well I'm I'm a I'm a chronic oversinker
and I have anxiety uh depression
um and I just got out of a physically
abusive uh marriage actually
um and uh second marriage and divorced
two and a half months ago
um and I I've met uh another female and
I'm just struggling I I don't know if I
should
let this develop or not
um if I'm ready for that
or if it's the right thing to do in the
first place
um two kids yeah with my first marriage
okay
um how long was your second marriage
nine months
yeah
well you just said yeah you judged your
that length of time I didn't what
happened man
she started
she started getting physically abusive
with me which she knew I've been in one
other relationship where that that has
been a problem
and she knew all about that I would
never you know I would never resort to
that and that
it is it got pretty bad and that that's
when I knew regardless of the length of
time and and I don't believe in I'm a
Christian I don't believe in divorce
um I don't I I I'm not believe it or not
I'm not the one who actually chose to
get divorced I chose to get separated
um because of the physical abuse and it
happened in front of my son one time uh
so I approached her about getting a
separate separating from her and then
her response was well I don't believe in
separation it's either a divorce or
yeah okay so I mean it sounds like
you're married to someone who is
struggling with a lot pretty immature
and
um
what is it about you that draws you to
volatile
abusive women
[Music]
struggling to answer myself to be honest
with you I I don't know
do you like to help
um are you just a pretty stable secure
guy
you said you're anxious you struggle
with some anxiousness and so that almost
is like uh Fire and Fire coming together
right
I've always been an agreeable person I I
don't like conflicts
um
I am stable I do you know I have three
jobs I I've worked I've done a lot of
things to better myself during that
I I was with my recent ex-wife three
years by the way so it was a nine month
marriage but we were together for three
years and I I worked on a lot she
pointed out a lot of things I needed
I'm just saying it out loud
I bet she I bet she let you know loud
and clear what you screwed up on and you
needed to fix right and I and I did I
made a lot in it I made a lot of effort
to change and and I'm thankful for it
because I did better myself
um
but at the same time
all I asked for from her was to be loved
I I never asked her I didn't want to
change I don't I know I don't want
anything other than you know obviously
her temper but I I didn't ask her to
change anything but I I accepted her
challenge to change myself and
I changed a lot of things I did but once
she started becoming physical I I knew
right then and there I I had to get away
yeah
um
so maybe that's an unfair question just
to lob on my part
um but I think it's something worth
considering
and if you go back and look at some of
the previous relationships you've been
in where people were violent with you
and my guess is the other ones where
they weren't violent there was some
volatility there is that fair
yes sir yeah there were some ups and
downs and some whoa and some yikes
um and so I would I think an important
thing to do
would be to write down
four or five or ten
things that were common across those
relationships
how'd you feel
what did they say
what did
um when there was a well there's a
disagreement
how was there some commonality there
because that's going to help be your
compass for no matter how good it feels
how
how attracted you are to somebody
how funny she is or how alive she makes
you feel
that's going to be a good road map for
hey I've been down this road before
it's at least enough to get you to ask
some questions right right and so when
it comes to I get this question a lot
um how long after I'm divorced should I
start dating how long should I I don't
have a I don't have a you need to wait
six months or four I don't have a thing
because a lot of marriages were done
five years before they actually get
divorced they were over for a long time
in some marriages like yours like hey I
just want to take a separation for 30
days and she's like well fine I file on
you and it's just over right and so some
of that is some smoke clearing
I think my general wisdom is
if you can't talk about your previous
relationship without your heartbeat
taking off on you you're probably not
ready
if you can't
walk through here's what happened
here's where what how where it was so
good and here's where it wasn't so good
and here's where we are now if you can't
do that you're probably not ready to
start dating
and I'll go one step further
um I think we get obsessive about
finding the next forever person
you have permission just to go have
friends man go hang out
you don't have to end up sleeping with
everybody you don't have to end up in a
romantic relationship with everybody you
can't just go have fun hang out
you know what I mean like there's a it's
hard once you're married it seems like
all right now we're back into the you
either go like I'll go play the field
bro that's dumb or
I gotta find the next to the next I mean
there's some Middle Ground there see
what I'm saying
yes sir I feel like my faith has allowed
me to change my viewpoint as far what
you just mentioned that's always
approached dating
that trap I put myself into but this
time after this second divorce I really
prayed about it I I've sought
um
Council from my church and they've
they've they said exactly what you just
said just just
focus on myself and just let you know
God show me the way and well but some of
some of that language is kind of you
gotta be careful about that
right because it's like gosh is gonna
he's just gonna put the person in front
I mean you gotta go out right I know
people who are still just sitting at
home waiting like nope I've been praying
and God's just gonna send them out and
it's like well dude you gotta leave your
house right so it's both end it's both
end
see what I'm saying right gotcha but I
don't think that means
I'm not going to tell you if you've met
somebody that's kind and great and just
seems like a good human being to be
around am I gonna say like no you cut
that person off that's that would be
dumb on my part
I also think
you're o for two on marriages right
yes sir so
um and my guess is you had some volatile
dating relationships before those
marriages are in between them is that
fair
yes sir so maybe before I get back in
the batter's box I am going to get with
a hitting instructor and figure out what
I'm doing wrong with my swing
that makes a lot of sense and when
you're in the like when you do it that
way you're not worried about what the
pitcher's throwing you're worried about
your swing mechanics and I think I'm a
sports writer so you're you're talking
right to me there you go so you're not
throwing you're not worried about what
the pitcher's gonna throw
I'm worried about how my stance is and
how my feet are and how my hips turn and
how my you know you know all that stuff
on my wrist turnover so all that to say
is I would get somebody just to walk
through with you and a good counselor
can do that for you they can walk back
in time with you also a couple of wise
men that are 10 or 15 years older than
you that would just agree to have coffee
with you once a week
or once a month
that could be amazing and you could say
hey I've had this with women I clearly
I'm not good at dating or being married
can y'all help
and the dudes love giving advice to each
other right
right but I think having some wisdom
there from some people who have been
there maybe talk to some folks who've
been divorced before and are in marriage
number two or are dating who have got
some wisdom on you that can walk you
through and say hey here's been my
experience here's what here's some
pitfalls that I fell into here's some
mistakes I made here's some things that
I I wish I'd done again and that can
just be some great great wisdom but I
think
you need to get to the root of why do I
think so little about Ryan that I keep
ending up in these
relationships where I am used as
the soil for somebody else to grow
why am I
always the gasoline for somebody else's
engine
because you've got more value in
relationships than that man
you're worth more to those relationships
than you just making sure
that the other person can chew you up
and spit you out
and I'll even go one step further
volatility in a relationship actually is
kind of fun
like fighting making up
hooking up like all it's fun like
there's some energy in there there's
there's the words I hear are alive
people say like I felt alive I felt
alive
and that's cool but I'll tell you you
know what also was cool warmth
laughter
fights
being silly
and I have found as I've gotten older
that seeking
aliveness inside of the Comfort instead
of trying to squeeze Comfort out of ah
chaos has been a much more sustainable
path for relationships and so I tell you
you know volatility you know Bonkers you
know yelling and screaming you know
punching and kicking I want you to
practice peace
I'm gonna send you a copy of building a
non-anxious life I'm gonna send you a
copy of the book
um about this very thing
and it may be brand new to you man I'm
gonna challenge you to get with somebody
and y'all work through these steps how
do I create this life I map it out for
you in the book how to create a
non-anxious life and when I do that I'm
going to create some boundaries that
then these new relationships I'm just
not gonna cross
it's not gonna cross I'm gonna begin to
see chaos coming
I'm going to begin to feel my body
because it starts gearing up when things
get chaotic and volatile it knows it's
coming and I'm gonna just choose to say
hey thanks but no thanks I'm good I want
to give my kids I want to get myself I
want to give my future
patience kindness and peace and laughter
just a much better way to live